This is Hidden Brain from NPR. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In May 2007, an artist living in Chicago moved into a new place. It was a small room with white walls. The interior design was minimalist. There was a bed, a desk, a computer, a lamp, and a paintball gun. A fix to the gun was a webcam. It live streamed the room to the internet. Anyone could look in and anyone could take control of the gun, aim and fire. At all hours of the day and night, the paintball gun would spring to life
这里是NPR的Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedanta。2007年5月，一位住在芝加哥的艺术家搬进了一个新住处。那是一个有着白色墙壁的小房间，室内设计走极简主义风格。房间里有一张床、一张书桌、一台电脑、一盏灯和一把彩弹枪。枪上安装了一个网络摄像头，将房间的画面实时直播到互联网上。任何人都可以观看，也可以控制这把枪，进行瞄准和射击。无论白天还是黑夜，这把彩弹枪随时都会启动，
and begin shooting yellow pellets into the room. Some hit the walls or the furniture. Some hit the artist. I was shot at 70,000 times and I received 80 million hits on the internet from 128 countries. Wafa Bilal spent one whole month in the room, targeted tens of thousands of times by random strangers around the world. Why would he choose to do this? Wafa was born and raised in Iraq. He came to the US in the early 90s. I live this duality of living in two places. One is a comfort zone of United States, and the other one is the brothers was killed in an airstrike.
开始向房间里发射黄色弹丸。有些打在墙上或家具上，有些则打在艺术家身上。我被射击了7万次，在互联网上获得了来自128个国家的8000万次点击。Wafa Bilal在这个房间里待了整整一个月，被世界各地素不相识的陌生人瞄准了数万次。他为什么要选择这样做？Wafa在伊拉克出生长大，90年代初来到美国。我过着这种生活在两个地方的双重生活。一个是美国这个舒适区，另一个是我的兄弟在空袭中丧生的地方。
One of my brother, Haji, was killed in air to ground missile. And I didn't know what to do. Wafa is a performance artist, and he wanted to engage others in the conversation that was running through his mind. Three years after his brother's death, he got an idea. In January of 2007, I was watching TV and I was watching an interview with an American soldier. Sitting in the United States, the soldier directed drones to fire missiles thousands of miles away in the Iraqi desert. I was shocked how the soldier completely disconnected physically and emotionally from what happened on the ground of Iraq.
我的兄弟Haji死于空对地导弹。我不知道该怎么办。Wafa是一位行为艺术家，他想让其他人参与到他脑海中正在进行的对话中。在他兄弟去世三年后，他产生了一个想法。2007年1月，我正在看电视，看到了一位美国士兵的采访。那名士兵坐在美国，指挥无人机在数千英里外的伊拉克沙漠中发射导弹。我感到震惊的是，这名士兵在身体和情感上与伊拉克地面上发生的事情完全脱节了。
At the time, Wafa was living in Chicago. He came up with a proposal and presented it to a gallery. I said, I want to lock myself in the gallery space for 30 days and I get a built a robot connected to the internet and the robot shoots a pinball and viewers online could direct that gun and shoot it. I'm there you go that's another shot let's see this one from I says from Milwaukee. The idea was to turn ordinary people into drone operators who could target someone far away except in this case people would not be following orders. They would have a choice about whether to shoot and you could see the
当时，Wafa住在芝加哥。他提出了一个方案并提交给了一家画廊。我说，我想把自己锁在画廊空间里30天，我安装了一个连接到互联网的机器人，机器人会发射彩弹，在线观众可以指挥那把枪进行射击。你看，又是一枪，让我们看看这一枪来自哪里，说是来自密尔沃基。这个想法是将普通人变成无人机操作员，他们可以瞄准远处的某个人，只不过在这种情况下，人们并不是在执行命令。他们可以选择是否射击，而且你可以看到
human being on the other end. Wafa's suffering would be visible. When you are in this little room you see the sheer destruction but if you are online it becomes like a video game and that another thing that I wanted to connect with people, that there is real consequences to these actions. As the days went by, Wafas started to feel weak by the day. I thought I felt better. As the days went by, Wafa started to feel crushed by the experience. It's late at night. Feel extremely tired. But I'm afraid she goes to bed.
另一端是一个活生生的人。Wafa的痛苦是可见的。当你在这个小房间里时，你看到的是纯粹的破坏，但如果你在网上，它就变成了一个电子游戏，这也是我想与人们建立联系的另一件事，即这些行为会产生真实的后果。随着日子一天天过去，Wafa开始感到一天比一天虚弱。我以为我感觉好些了。随着日子一天天过去，Wafa开始感到被这种经历压垮了。已经是深夜了。感觉非常疲惫。但我很害怕，她去睡觉了。
In some ways, Wafa was attempting to do what civil disobedience movements around the world have done. He was deliberately putting himself in harm's way in order to draw attention to a problem and affect change. I have United States, I have Denmark, I have Ireland, I have the UK, I have United States, I have Denmark, I have Ireland, I have the UK, I have France, I canada, so it's not one place, it is almost a global shooting and I don't know. Somebody said imagine the damn nation will like this. Why did strangers who knew nothing about Wafa take it upon themselves to hurt him?
在某种程度上，Wafa试图做世界各地的公民不服从运动所做的事情。他故意让自己处于危险之中，以引起人们对某个问题的关注并促成改变。我有美国、丹麦、爱尔兰、英国、美国、丹麦、爱尔兰、英国、法国、加拿大，所以这不是一个地方，这几乎是一场全球性的射击，我不知道。有人说想象一下该死的国家会喜欢这样。为什么那些对Wafa一无所知的陌生人会主动去伤害他？
Do technology in modern life and the anonymity they offer make us less caring as human beings? On today's show, Building Empathy in a Connected and Confrontational World. This week on Hidden Brain, think deeply. We kick off our annual Summer Series, YouTube.O. Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. Just do it, just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick.
现代生活中的技术及其提供的匿名性是否让我们作为人类变得不那么有同情心了？在今天的节目中，在互联和对抗的世界中建立同理心。本周的Hidden Brain，深入思考。我们开启了年度夏季系列节目，YouTube.O。真实性是会传染的。我一直被拖进这一切，又踢又叫。关于你如何应对生活混乱的想法和建议。去做吧，去检查我的收件箱。去检查，去检查，去检查我的手机，很快。
With wisdom. We begin the series with an exploration of the power and the cost of empathy. By putting ourselves into the story of people who on the surface appeared different from us. We can recognize our common humanity with them and that can trigger empathy in a really natural way. Jamil Zaki is a psychologist at Stanford University. He's the author of the book, The War for Kindness, Building Empathy in a Fractured World. Jamil, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me.
带着智慧。我们以探索同理心的力量和代价开启了这个系列。通过将自己置于那些表面上看起来与我们不同的人的故事中。我们可以认识到我们与他们共同的人性，这可以以一种非常自然的方式触发同理心。Jamil Zaki是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《善良的战争：在破碎的世界中建立同理心》一书的作者。Jamil，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢邀请我。
You have a very powerful story about how you came to be interested in the subject of empathy. Tell me about your parents, where they are from, how they met, what they went through, and what you learned from the experience. So it turns out that in the early 1970s, Washington State University in Pullman had a program where they granted full scholarships for graduate studies to students from the world's poorest nations. My mother received the scholarship from Peru, and my father did not receive a scholarship, but nonetheless came to Washington State from Pakistan. So they traveled from Lima and Lahore, these two massive cities to the sleepy town of
你有一个关于你是如何对同理心这个主题产生兴趣的非常强大的故事。告诉我关于你父母的事，他们来自哪里，他们是如何相遇的，他们经历了什么，以及你从这段经历中学到了什么。事实证明，在20世纪70年代初，位于普尔曼的华盛顿州立大学有一个项目，为来自世界上最贫穷国家的学生提供研究生学习的全额奖学金。我母亲获得了来自秘鲁的奖学金，而我父亲没有获得奖学金，但尽管如此，他还是从巴基斯坦来到了华盛顿州立大学。所以他们从利马和拉合尔这两个巨大的城市旅行到了这个安静的小镇——
Pullman where they fell in love. When I think about my parents, I think the biggest thing that they had in common was their sense of foreignness in the US. They sort of took comfort in each other in a place that neither of them understood, but as they grew more comfortable with the US and were acclimated to it, they grew less comfortable with each other. And they divorced. They started splitting up when I was eight, but didn't finish until I was 12.
普尔曼，在那里他们坠入爱河。当我想到我的父母时，我认为他们最大的共同点是他们在美利坚合众国的陌生感。在一个他们都不了解的地方，他们从彼此身上获得安慰，但随着他们对美国越来越适应，他们对彼此却越来越不舒服。于是他们离婚了。我在八岁时他们开始分居，但直到我12岁才正式离婚。
And theirs was a long and acrimonious split and I am their only child. And so a lot of my childhood was spent kind of bouncing around between their houses and it really felt like I was bouncing between parallel universes because their priorities and values and fears are really as far apart as their hometowns. So I would often feel confused, you know, as a small child, I would try to, when I was with my mom, figure out the rules that governed her heart and mind and make them true for myself.
他们的分手过程漫长且充满怨恨，而我是他们唯一的孩子。所以我的童年大部分时间都是在他们的房子之间来回奔波，这真的感觉就像我在平行宇宙之间穿梭，因为他们的优先事项、价值观和恐惧与他们的家乡一样相去甚远。所以我经常感到困惑，你知道，作为一个小孩，当我和妈妈在一起时，我会试图弄清楚支配她内心和思想的规则，并使它们对我自己也适用。
But then when I would go to my dad's house, those same rules would stop working. And it was just very confusing, and it felt, I think, to all three of us, like I would really have to choose one of my parents and give up on really knowing the other. But I knew that I had to try for all of our sake. So I did and I kind of kept working at it and eventually got better and learned to tune myself to my parents' different frequencies. And that kind of saved me as a kid. I think empathy saved me. Not because it's easy, it was work. I was thinking of my parents' divorce as an empathy gym for me that forced me to work out my ability to care about and understand other people. And you, as you said, described this as an empathy gym, were there times when you failed to show them empathy?
但当我回到爸爸家时，同样的规则就不管用了。这非常令人困惑，我想我们三个人都觉得，我必须在父母之间做出选择，并放弃真正了解另一方。但我知道为了我们所有人，我必须尝试。所以我做到了，我不断努力，最终变得更好，并学会了调整自己以适应父母不同的频率。这在某种程度上拯救了小时候的我。我认为同理心拯救了我。不是因为它容易，而是因为这是一种工作。我把父母的离婚看作是我的同理心健身房，它迫使我锻炼自己关心和理解他人的能力。正如你所说，你将其描述为同理心健身房，有没有那么几次你未能对他们表现出同理心？
I mean, I must imagine that as a small child, it must have been very difficult in many ways to comprehend what was happening and why these two adults were fighting over you and each was demanding that you see things from their point of view. Oh, absolutely. I mean, one of the big realizations for me as a kid was realizing that both of them were in pain. I think as a child, it's very easy to focus on your own perspective and what you're going through. And to blame others, especially adults,
我的意思是，我必须想象，作为一个小孩，在许多方面理解正在发生的事情，以及为什么这两个成年人为了你而争吵，并且每个人都要求你从他们的角度看问题，一定是非常困难的。哦，当然。我的意思是，作为一个孩子，我最大的感悟之一就是意识到他们两个都在痛苦中。我认为作为一个孩子，很容易专注于自己的视角和你正在经历的事情。并责怪他人，尤其是成年人，
I think when I realized that my parents were both struggling just like I was, it actually made me feel kinship towards them and made it easier to understand that I could connect with both of them. In fact, because what we were going through wasn't that different. Talk a little bit about the benefits of empathy. There's been a lot of work that looks at what happens when people receive empathy from their partners, for example, or from their doctors. Oh, yeah. I mean, in many cases, empathy benefits all parties involved. So, for instance, patients of empathic doctors are more satisfied with their care, but are also more likely to follow
我想当我意识到我的父母和我一样都在挣扎时，这实际上让我对他们产生了亲近感，并让我更容易理解我可以与他们两人建立联系。事实上，因为我们正在经历的事情并没有什么不同。谈谈同理心的好处吧。有很多研究观察了当人们从伴侣或医生那里获得同理心时会发生什么。哦，是的。我的意思是，在许多情况下，同理心对所有相关方都有利。例如，得到有同理心的医生照顾的患者对他们的护理更满意，但也更有可能遵循
doctors' recommendations, which is important for things like preventative care, and spouses of empathic partners are happier in their marriages. But one thing that I think people don't realize as much is that people who experience empathy for others also benefit. It's not just receiving it, but giving it helps us too. So people who are relatively high in empathy, for instance, are less likely to become depressed, feeling empathy for others reduces our stress and adolescence who are able to pick out other people's emotions accurately
医生的建议，这对预防性护理等事情很重要，而有同理心的伴侣的配偶在婚姻中更幸福。但我认为人们没有意识到的一点是，那些对他人产生同理心的人也会受益。不仅仅是接受它，给予它也对我们有帮助。例如，同理心相对较高的人不太可能变得抑郁，对他人产生同理心可以减轻我们的压力，而那些能够准确识别他人情绪的青少年
are better adjusted during middle school. Now, parents everywhere recognize the value of empathy. We have courses and classes that try and teach children empathy. I came by this clip on Sesame Street featuring the actor Mark Ruffalo and the character, Marie, take a listen to the clip. Marie. What? Did I tell you about that time when I lost my favorite teddy bear?
在中学期间适应得更好。现在，各地的父母都认识到了同理心的价值。我们有课程和班级试图教孩子们同理心。我偶然发现了芝麻街上的这个片段，由演员Mark Ruffalo和角色Marie主演，听听这个片段。Marie。什么？我有没有告诉你我丢失最喜欢的泰迪熊的那次经历？
Oh no. It was... This is very sad. Did you about that time when I lost my favorite teddy bear. Oh no. It was... This is very sad. Did you love that teddy bear? I love that teddy bear. Oh, I can imagine exactly how it feels. It's really sad feeling. It makes me want to cry like this.
哦，不。那是……这太令人难过了。你有没有告诉你我丢失最喜欢的泰迪熊的那次经历。哦，不。那是……这太令人难过了。你爱那个泰迪熊吗？我爱那个泰迪熊。哦，我可以想象那种感觉。这真是一种悲伤的感觉。它让我想像这样哭。
It was sad. It was so sad. But you know what? What? You know what empathy is. I do. That was empathy. What? You could understand how I was feeling, exactly how I was feeling and understood it. That's empathy. I said now. Jamil, you've used a similar kind of scenario to explain empathy. Someone's talking with a friend, the friend gets a phone call, walk me through the rest of that scenario and the three components that you've identified that make up empathy. Yeah, so again, imagine that you're sitting with a friend having lunch and they receive a phone call and whatever the person on the other side of the line says makes them visibly
这很悲伤。这太悲伤了。但你知道吗？什么？你知道什么是同理心吗？我知道。那就是同理心。什么？你可以理解我的感受，确切地知道我的感受并理解它。那就是同理心。我说现在。Jamil，你用过类似的情景来解释同理心。某人正在和朋友交谈，朋友接到了一个电话，带我走过那个情景的其余部分，以及你确定的构成同理心的三个组成部分。是的，再次想象一下，你正和朋友坐在一起吃午饭，他们接到了一个电话，电话那头的人说的任何话都让他们明显地
upset. You don't know what's wrong, but your friend starts to cry and it's obvious that something is wrong. Well, as you see this, a bunch of things might happen inside you. First, you might become upset yourself, sort of vicariously catching their feeling. That's what psychologists often call emotional empathy. You might also try to figure out what's wrong, what they're feeling, and why. That's what we call cognitive empathy. You might also try to figure out what's wrong, what they're feeling, and why. That's what we call cognitive empathy. And if you're a good friend at least, you probably will feel concerned for what they're going through and a desire for their well-being to improve. That's what psychologists call empathic concern or compassion. And even though these pieces of empathy sometimes go together, they also
心烦意乱。你不知道出了什么问题，但你的朋友开始哭泣，很明显出了什么问题。好吧，当你看到这一幕时，你的内心可能会发生很多事情。首先，你自己可能会感到不安，这是一种替代性的感受。这就是心理学家通常所说的情感同理心。你可能还会试图弄清楚出了什么问题，他们的感受是什么，以及为什么。这就是我们所说的认知同理心。你可能还会试图弄清楚出了什么问题，他们的感受是什么，以及为什么。这就是我们所说的认知同理心。如果你至少是一个好朋友，你可能会对他们正在经历的事情感到担忧，并希望他们的幸福感得到改善。这就是心理学家所说的同理心关怀或同情心。即使这些同理心的片段有时会结合在一起，它们也
split apart in interesting ways. So for instance, different brain systems support emotional and cognitive empathy and empathic concern. And different groups of people struggle with different flavors of empathy. People with autism spectrum disorders, for instance, struggle sometimes to understand others, their cognitive empathy, but don't struggle as much to share other people's emotions or care about what other people feel. Individuals with psychopathy have the opposite profile. They're often perfectly able to understand what other people feel, but they don't share
以有趣的方式分开了。例如，不同的大脑系统支持情感同理心、认知同理心和同理心关怀。不同的人群在不同类型的同理心上会遇到困难。例如，患有自闭症谱系障碍的人有时难以理解他人，即他们的认知同理心，但并不难分享他人的情绪或关心他人的感受。精神病患者则有相反的特征。他们通常完全能够理解他人的感受，但他们并不分享
those emotions. That's fascinating. It's almost like these are different muscle groups and you need all the muscle groups to be functioning to in some ways actualize your full capacity for empathy. I love that analogy. Yeah, that's a perfect way of putting it. So at the same time that parents and books and motivational speakers and fate traditions cite the value of empathy, there is also some evidence that empathy might be changing over time and not necessarily in a good way.
那些情绪。这太迷人了。这几乎就像这些是不同的肌肉群，你需要所有的肌肉群都能正常工作，才能在某种程度上实现你完整的同理心能力。我喜欢这个类比。是的，这是一种完美的表达方式。所以，在父母、书籍、励志演说家和命运传统引用同理心价值的同时，也有一些证据表明同理心可能会随着时间的推移而改变，而且不一定是朝着好的方向。
U-Site research that compares the average level of empathy in 2009 to the average in 1979. Yeah, so this is work by Sarah Conrath and her colleagues using the most sort of famous and well-known scale to measure empathy, which is just a questionnaire. In this questionnaire, people see a number of statements and they're asked how much they agree with that statement, from one, not at all, to five, extremely. So a sample statement might be, I often have tender, concerned feelings for people less fortunate than myself.
你引用了比较2009年平均同理心水平与1979年平均水平的研究。是的，这是Sarah Conrath和她的同事使用最著名和最广为人知的同理心测量量表所做的工作，这只是一个问卷。在这个问卷中，人们看到许多陈述，并被问及他们对该陈述的同意程度，从1（完全不同意）到5（非常同意）。所以一个样本陈述可能是，我经常对那些不如我幸运的人有温柔、关心的感觉。
Or I try to look at everyone's side of a disagreement before I make a decision. So a series of questions like that give you a sort of empathy score, again from one to five. People have taken this questionnaire over several decades, and if you compare their scores over time, they've been dwindling or eroding. And what's more troubling is that a lot of this decline happened pretty recently sort of since the turn of the 21st century. Let's talk about some of the reasons this might be happening. You offer various theories
或者我在做决定之前会尝试从分歧的每一方来看待问题。所以一系列这样的问题会给你一个同理心分数，同样是从1到5。人们在几十年里都做过这个问卷，如果你比较他们随时间的分数，它们一直在减少或侵蚀。更令人不安的是，这种下降大部分发生在最近，也就是21世纪之交以来。让我们谈谈这可能发生的一些原因。你在书中提出了各种理论
in the book. Among people 18 to 34 for example, ten times as many people live alone today as did in 1950. You say that more than half of all residents in Paris and Stockholm live alone in some parts of Manhattan and Los Angeles, that number tops 90%. Is there a link between going solo and the amount of empathy we feel for others? It's hard to say, you know, and I do want to be clear that in looking at any demographic trends over time and trying to link them to empathy decline, we're necessarily speculating, right? There's no way to run an experiment where you have history occur multiple times and fiddle with different pieces of it to see what causes a decline in empathy.
例如，在18到34岁的人群中，今天独自生活的人数是1950年的十倍。你说巴黎和斯德哥尔摩的所有居民中有一半以上独自生活，在曼哈顿和洛杉矶的部分地区，这个数字超过了90%。独自生活与我们对他人的同理心之间是否存在联系？很难说，你知道，我确实想明确一点，在观察任何人口趋势随时间的变化并试图将其与同理心下降联系起来时，我们必然是在推测，对吧？没有办法进行一个实验，让历史发生多次，并摆弄其中的不同部分，看看是什么导致了同理心的下降。
But certainly, you know, you can point to big shifts in the way that people live, and one of them is that we're becoming more urban and more solitary. And when we interact with people, it's often in more transactional ways, right? Sort of some of the regular rituals that used to bring us into contact with other people often are giving way to more solitary pursuits. So there's some evidence, for instance, that anonymous interactions do not favor empathy. So I don't know, there's not data specifically on solitary living, but to the extent that living in a giant city
但当然，你知道，你可以指出人们生活方式的巨大转变，其中之一就是我们变得越来越城市化，越来越孤独。当我们与人互动时，通常是以更交易的方式，对吧？一些曾经让我们与他人接触的常规仪式往往正在让位于更孤独的追求。所以有一些证据表明，匿名互动不利于同理心。所以我不知道，没有关于独自生活的具体数据，但就生活在一个巨大的城市而言
but by yourself, where most of the people who you see are total strangers, there's some evidence that suggests that perhaps that might have an effect on our empathy. And of course, one of the other places where anonymity rules is the internet. And when you look at some of the changes that have unfolded and the timetable of those changes, they do coincide at least,
但独自一人，你看到的大多数人都是完全的陌生人，有一些证据表明这可能会对我们的同理心产生影响。当然，匿名性占主导地位的另一个地方是互联网。当你观察已经展开的一些变化以及这些变化的时间表时，它们至少在相关性上与互联网技术的兴起相吻合。我想知道，是否有理由想象这两者之间存在联系，即我们在网上、Twitter或社交媒体上与彼此建立的联系，在那里我们通常不知道我们在与谁交流，谁在听，谁不在听？这在某种程度上可能是同理心下降的原因吗？这当然是有可能的。
correlationally with the rise of internet technologies. And I'm wondering, is there reason to imagine that there's a connection between these two things, that the connections we have with one another online and on Twitter or social media, where we often don't know who we are communicating where they're who's listening or who's not listening? Could this in some ways be behind this decline in empathy? It certainly is possible.
我认为互联网和社交媒体，我不认为它们本质上是反社会的。在某种程度上，你可以把互联网看作是人类有史以来最大的同理心机会。我们有机会随时随地以他们自己的方式与世界各地的人们建立联系，并以同情心回应。我的意思是，如果你回去读10或15年前的《连线》杂志，人们在诗意地谈论互联网如何能将我们所有人聚集在一起，形成一个全球社区。我认为在某些显而易见的方式上，这种情况并不总是发生，我认为这与
I think that the internet and social media, I don't think of them as inherently anti-social. In a way, you can think of the internet as humanity's greatest, empathic opportunity ever. We have the chance to connect with people around the world at any time on their own terms and respond with compassion. I mean, I think if you go back and read Wired, you know, 10 or 15 years ago, people were waxing poetic about the way that the internet could bring us all together into a global community. I think in some obvious ways that hasn't always occurred, and I think that has to do in
部分我们倾向于使用互联网的方式有关，这些方式可能不是同理心积极的。例如，在网上，我们通常没有机会在实时互动中看到彼此的面孔和声音，那种我们在离线相处时拥有的丰富性。相反，我们看到的是头像和一串串文字，这些可能不是同理心的良好触发因素。Juliana Schroder和她的同事做了一项很棒的研究，他们让人们描述他们的政治观点，以音频记录的形式。然后他们让另一组人听这些音频记录或阅读它们的文字记录。他们发现，如果人们只是在阅读，他们更有可能将他们正在阅读其观点的人非人化。
part with some of the ways that we tend to use the internet that might not be empathy-positive. So for instance, oftentimes online, we don't have a chance to see each other's faces and voices in real-time interactions, the kind of richness that we have when we hang out offline. Instead we see avatars and strings of text, and those might not be great triggers for empathy. There's a great study by Juliana Schroder and her colleagues where they had people describe their political opinions, sort of, in an audio recording. They then had a separate group of people listen to those audio recordings or read a transcript of them. And what they found was that people were more likely to dehumanize the person whose opinion
而如果他们听到那个人的声音，他们就不太可能将那个人非人化。所以这几乎就像我们在上网时抛弃了一些让我们能够检测彼此真实人性的线索。这其中有一个深刻的讽刺，不是吗，Jimmy？我的意思是，当我们生活在这些大城市时，我们与许多其他人紧密相连，但在某些方面我们并没有与他们建立联系，互联网也是如此，当我们有能力
was they were reading about if they were only reading it. Whereas if they were hearing the person's voice, they were less likely to dehumanize that individual. So it's almost as though we're leaving behind when we go online some of the cues that allow us to detect each other's real humanity And there's a deep irony there isn't that Jimmy I mean when we live in these big cities we're living cheek by jowl with lots of other people But in some ways we're not connecting with them and the same goes with the internet when we have the capacity
与大量的人建立联系，但我们却以一种肤浅的方式而不是这种更深层的方式进行联系。这很讽刺，不是吗？我的意思是，在城市里，例如，我们看到的人比人类历史上任何时候都多，但我们认识的人却更少。这几乎就像我们的互动
To connect with large numbers about the people, but we're connecting in often the superficial way instead of this deeper way. It is ironic, isn't it? I mean, in cities, for instance, we see more people than we ever did in human history, but we know fewer of them. And it almost is as though our interactions
倾向于支持一种对彼此的非人化视角。我的意思是，我知道在曼哈顿拥挤的街区中被困在交通中或试图穿行是什么感觉。人们对我来说不再是人，而是我路上的障碍。我认为这在现代语境下通常就是这种感觉。当我们回来时，更多关于同理心的迹象，以及为什么有同理心有时会对你有害。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。
sort of favor a dehumanized perspective on each other. I mean, I know what a sort of stuck-in traffic or trying to make my way down a crowded block in Manhattan. People become not people, but obstacles for me on my way. And I think that that's sort of the way that it can often feel in modern contexts. When we come back, more on the signs of empathy and why being empathetic can sometimes be bad for you. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
Jameel Zaki是《善良的战争：在破碎的世界中建立同理心》的作者。他在斯坦福大学进行同理心研究。Jermia，经历过可怕痛苦的人可以以不同的方式做出反应。有些人转向内心以避免未来的痛苦，而另一些人则转向外部。他们对他人的痛苦表现出同理心。我觉得我看到的研究表明了这两点。你能谈谈这些研究，以及为什么人们在经历创伤后可能会朝着一个方向或
Jameel Zaki is the author of the War of a Kindness, building empathy in a fractured world. He conducts research on empathy at Stanford University. Jermia people who have been through terrible suffering can respond in different ways. Some people turn inward to avoid future pain while others turn outward. They show empathy for the suffering of other people. I feel like I've seen research studies that show both these things. Can you talk about these studies and why people might go in one direction or
另一个方向发展吗？是的，你知道，我认为我们经常认为创伤，你知道，比如经历战争、被袭击或遭受可怕的伤害，是那些，正如你很好地表达的那样，将我们拉向彼此，甚至创伤可能会自我延续。我们经常听到暴力循环或受伤的人伤害他人的想法。这在某些情况下当然是真的，但有很多研究实际上对心理学家所说的“源于痛苦的利他主义”更有希望。
another after the experience trauma? Yeah, you know, I think that we often think of trauma, you know, sort of things like being through a war or being assaulted or suffering a terrible injury as things that, again, as you put it nicely sort of draw us into each other, or even that trauma might perpetuate itself. We often hear about cycles of violence or the idea that hurt people, hurt people. And that's certainly true in some cases, but there is a lot of research that's actually much more hopeful on what psychologists call altruism-born of suffering.
这就是说，有时当我们经历过巨大的痛苦时，这实际上会让我们更关心他人和他们的痛苦。所以也有各种各样的例子。例如，遭受成瘾折磨的人经常改变他们的生活并成为成瘾咨询师。遭受袭击的人经常改变他们的生活并成为袭击咨询师，因为他们更敏锐地与他人痛苦的频率产生共鸣。心理学家并不真正了解是什么导致人们在经历痛苦时朝着一个方向或另一个方向发展，但他们确定的一个重要因素
This is the idea that sometimes when we've gone through great pain, that actually sort of opens us up to caring more about other people and their suffering. So there are all sorts of examples of that as well. So for instance, people who have suffered from addiction often change their lives and become addiction counselors. People who have been assaulted often change their lives and become assault counselors, sort of because they resonate with the frequency of other people suffering more acutely. Psychologists don't really know that much about what causes people when they experience suffering to go in one direction or another, but one important factor that they have identified
是我们从他人那里得到的支持。所以，如果在创伤之后，一个人能够找到一个支持他们的社区，那么他们就更有可能从自己的创伤中恢复过来，他们也可能更有可能转过身来为他人提供这种支持。我正在思考Michael Wall和Nile Bransk等人所做的研究，观察当你提醒人们过去的创伤时，例如提醒美国人9-11袭击，美国人变得更愿意支持或容忍反恐斗争中的严厉审讯技术。在某种程度上，这似乎非常直观，你觉得你已经
is the support that we receive from other people. So if after a trauma, an individual is able to find a community of others who support them, well then they're more likely to recover from their own trauma and they might also be more likely to turn around and provide that support to others. I'm thinking about research that Michael Wall and Nile Bransk and others have done looking at how when you remind people of past traumas you remind Americans for example of the 9-11 attacks Americans become more willing to endorse or tolerate harsh interrogation techniques in the fight against terrorism. And in some ways at one level, this seems very intuitive that you feel like you've been
经历了一些糟糕的事情，我提醒你经历过的糟糕事情。你内心的一部分会说，我不希望那件糟糕的事情再次发生，这增加了我允许可能导致他人伤害的行为或举止的意愿，而我本来可能会说，等一下。是的，绝对。我的意思是，我认为这在两个方面都有影响，对吧？我的意思是，我认为提醒人们集体创伤，例如，可以使他们对局外人更加警惕，正如你所说，甚至更愿意支持对局外人的暴力或侵略。但思考一个共同的威胁也是将群体内的人拉得更近的一种方式。
through something bad, and I remind you of the bad thing you've been through. And there's a part of you that says, I don't want that bad thing to happen again, and that increases my willingness to permit actions or behaviors that might I might otherwise say hang on a second. This is going to cause harm to other people Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I think that that it cuts both ways, right? I mean, I think reminding people of collective trauma for instance can make them more weary of trauma, for instance, can make them more weary of outsiders and sort of more, as you say, willing to even endorse violence or aggression towards outsiders. But thinking of a common threat is also one way to bring people within a group closer
我记得9-11之后，美国人真的觉得我们都是一体的，因为我们正在共同面对这种非常深刻的创伤。同样，有各种各样的证据表明，当人们感到他们面临共同的威胁时，他们会团结在一起。所以这真的很有趣，你真正指出的是，同理心在某种程度上具有这种双刃剑的特质，一方面它
together. I remember after 9-11, the way that Americans really felt like we were all won because we were facing this really deep trauma together. And likewise, there's all sorts of evidence that when people feel that they have a common threat that they're facing, they band together. So it's really interesting what you're really pointing out is that empathy in some ways has this double-edged sword quality to it, which is on the one hand it's
促使我们向外看，但它在某种程度上也受到关于谁在我们的内群体中，谁不在我们的内群体中的因素的驱动。心理学家Paul Bloom写了《反同理心：理性同情心的案例》一书，他认为同理心往往是狭隘的，往往是有偏见的，这就是为什么当我们要求人们有同理心时，我们实际上是在邀请他们产生偏见。这是真的吗？我认为Paul在某些方面是正确的。绝对的，同理心往往是狭隘地开始的。
prompting us to be outward looking, but it's also driven in some ways by factors about who's in our in-group and who's not in our in-group. The psychologist Paul Bloom who wrote the book against empathy, the case for rational compassion, he argues that empathy tends to be parochial and it tends to be biased, and that's why when we ask people to be empathic, we're really inviting them to be prejudiced. Is that true? I think that Paul is right in certain ways. Absolutely empathy sort of begins parochially.
我们本能的同理心可能更多地被驱动向我们的部落内的人，而不是部落外的人。我经常想到催产素，这种导致我们与他人建立联系的化学物质。我们经常认为催产素是爱情药物或拥抱荷尔蒙，但事实证明，如果你给人们鼻内注射催产素，例如，他们会变得更关心群体内的人，但对
Our instinctive empathy might be more driven towards people in our tribe than outside of it. I often think of oxytocin, this chemical that sort of causes us to bond to other people. We often think of oxytocin as the love drug or the cuddle hormone, but it turns out that if you give people oxytocin intranasally, for instance, they become more caring about people in their group, but less caring about
群体外的人不那么关心。本质上，在这种情况下，提高人们的同理心意味着提高他们的狭隘主义。我认为Paul和我分歧很大的一个地方是我们如何处理这些信息。所以Paul，我认为，相信，好吧，同理心往往是狭隘的，对内部人与外部人有偏见，所以我们应该完全放弃它。我的想法不同。我认为这是同理心运作方式的一个问题，但我试图让我们关注这样一个事实，即我们可以控制我们如何产生同理心，并对我们部署的方式做出选择
people outside their group. In essence, sort of turning up, people's empathy, in that case, means turning up their parochialism. I think a big place where Paul and I differ is on what we do with this information. So Paul, I think, believes that, okay, empathy tends to be parochial and biased towards insiders versus outsiders, so we should give up on it altogether. I think differently. I think that that's a problem with how empathy tends to operate, but I try to focus us on the fact that we can control how we empathize and make choices about the way that we deploy
我们的关怀。如果我们认识到，嘿，我正在以一种狭隘的、部落的方式产生同理心，我们可以尝试做出不同的选择，并扩大我们的同理心，甚至对那些与我们不同的人。你和警察做了一些非常有趣的工作，你运用了你刚才谈到的这个见解。告诉我关于那项工作，并告诉我有时正确的建议实际上可能是告诉人们表现得不那么有同理心。
our caring. And if we recognize that hey I'm empathizing in a parochial way in a tribal way, we can try to make a different choice and broaden our empathy even towards people who are different for ourselves. You've done some very interesting work with police officers where you brought to bear this insight that you just talked about. Tell me about that work and tell me about how sometimes the right recommendation might actually be to tell people behave a little less empathetically.
是的，所以为了这本书，我分析了华盛顿州的刑事司法培训中心。虽然这些警官对公民非常有同理心，但他们对其他警官更有同理心，这包括那些参与了潜在警察不当行为的警官，对吧？所以当我在那里时，有一个警察射杀了一名名叫Antonio Zambrano Montez的未武装男子的案件。警察射杀了一名名叫Antonio Zambrano Montez的未武装男子。在我访问CJTC期间，参与那次射击的警官。他们根本没有被起诉。
Yeah, so for the book I profiled Washington State's Criminal Justice Training Center. Although these officers were very empathic towards citizens, they were even more empathic towards fellow police officers, and that included fellow police officers who had engaged in potential police misconduct, right? So while I was there, there was a case of police officers who had shot an unarmed man named Antonio Zambrano Montez. police officers who had shot an unarmed man named Antonio Zambrano Montez. And during my visit to CJTC, the officers involved in that shooting. They're not indicted at all.
所以这对华盛顿州的许多人来说似乎是对正义的嘲弄。但CJTC的人坚持认为这些人是好人，只是犯了一个错误。那种对他们自己群体中人的同理心，我觉得，这只是我的观点，可能干扰了他们理解世界其他地方如何看待所发生事情的能力。事实上，这与我的朋友Emil Bruno的研究是一致的。他研究了许多不同群体间语境下的狭隘同理心。
So that seemed like a travesty of justice to many people in Washington State. But the people at CJTC were adamant that these were good guys who had just made a mistake. That level of empathy for people in their own group, I feel, and this is just my perspective, might have interfered with their ability to understand how the rest of the world saw what had happened. And, in fact, this is consistent with research by my friend Emil Bruno. He's studied sort of parochial empathy in a lot of different intergroup contexts.
他发现，有时如果你想预测某人何时愿意对局外人表现出侵略性，或不愿意与冲突另一方的人妥协，仅仅测量他们是否对外部的人有同理心是不够的。你还必须测量他们对
And what he finds is that sometimes if you want to predict when someone will be willing to be aggressive towards outsiders or unwilling to compromise with someone on the other side of a conflict, it's not enough to measure whether they empathize with the people on the outside. You have to also measure how empathic they are
他们自己的群体有多大的同理心。事实证明，那些对群体内的人非常有同理心的人，即使他们也对局外人有同理心，也不愿意妥协，不愿意做任何可能威胁他们自己部落的事情。所以这表明，有时如果我们想向其他文化、向政治或种族分歧另一方的人开放自己，也许我们应该开始做的不仅仅是试图去了解他们并对他们产生更多的同理心，而是要认识到
to their own group. And it turns out that people who are extraordinarily empathic towards people in their group, even if they're also empathic towards outsiders, are unwilling to compromise, unwilling to do anything that could threaten their own tribe. So what this suggests is that sometimes if we want to open ourselves up to other cultures, to people on the other side of a political or racial divide, maybe what we should start out doing is not just trying to get to know them and empathize more with them, but to recognize
如果我们对我们的群体产生了太多的同理心，我们将无法在情感上保持灵活。我想谈谈同理心的另一个悖论。你看到大约50%的肿瘤学家报告说，当他们向患者传达坏消息时，会感到强烈的伤心。所以，即使同理心在医疗环境中是积极结果的非常强大的驱动力，例如，它似乎也伴随着一些个人代价。是的，事实上，即使让医学生模拟传达坏消息也会让他们感到焦虑，
if we're empathizing so much with our group that will be unable to be flexible emotionally. I want to talk about another paradox of empathy. You see that about 50% of oncologists report feeling intense heartbreak when they communicate bad news to patients. So even as empathy is a very powerful driver of positive outcomes in medical settings, for example, it also seems to come at some personal cost. Yeah, in fact, even having medical students simulate delivering bad news makes them anxious,
使他们的手掌开始出汗，心脏开始加速。同理心通常是有益的，包括在医疗环境中，对接受它的人来说。但对给予它的人来说，这可能是一种职业危害。我知道你的一个朋友是心理治疗师，她避免在一天结束时安排抑郁症患者，在某种程度上也是出于同样的原因。是的，是的，因为她觉得他们的负面情绪会渗入她，并使她无法与家人良好互动。我认为这是同理心对从事护理职业的人来说的双刃剑的一部分。一方面，许多这些
makes their palms start to sweat and their heart start to race. Empathy is usually beneficial including in medical contexts for the people who receive it. But it can be an occupational hazard for the people who give it. I understand that a friend of yours is a psychotherapist and she avoids scheduling depressed patients at the end of the day for in some ways the same reason. Yeah, yeah, because she feels as though their negative mood will seep into her and sort of leave her unable to interact well with her family. And I think this is part of the double edged sword of empathy for people in caring professions. On the one hand, many of these
人被一种对他人超自然的关怀所驱动而从事他们的工作。但另一方面，同样的关怀也会导致他们迷失自我，特别是如果他们处于非常紧张的医疗环境中，他们被长期包围在他人深刻的痛苦中。结果，我认为从事护理职业的人经常觉得他们陷入了在充分照顾他人与可能磨损自己或关闭自己之间的两难境地。这是医疗行业中所谓的防御性非人化。这种想法是，医生和其他医疗保健专业人员觉得他们有时不得不
people are driven to their work by a preternatural care for others. But on the other hand, that same care can cause them to lose themselves, especially if they're in really intense medical settings where they're surrounded by chronically surrounded by other people's deep suffering. And as a result, oftentimes I think people in caring professions feel like they're stuck in a double bind between caring for other people adequately but potentially grinding themselves down or turning themselves off. This is something that is called in the medical profession, defensive dehumanization. The idea that physicians and other healthcare professionals feel like they sometimes have to
关闭他们的同理心，停止将他们的病人视为人，只是为了让他们继续做人。你引用了Mark Penser在20世纪70年代进行的一项有趣的研究，这是这种防御行为的另一个例子，人们避免在可能被要求表现出同理心的情况下。那项研究是什么，他发现了什么？是的，这是一项引人入胜的研究，Penser在一个繁忙的大学生会中心中间放置了一张要求慈善捐款的桌子。桌子上有一个慈善捐款请求，有时上面有一张快乐孩子的照片，有时有一张受苦孩子的照片。有时桌子上没有人看管，
turn off their empathy and stop seeing their patients as people just so they can go on being people. You cite this interesting study that Mark Penser conducted in the 1970s, which is another example of this kind of defensive behavior where people avoid situations where they might be called upon to demonstrate empathy. What was the study and what did he find? Yeah, this was a fascinating study where Panser placed a table asking for charitable donations in the middle of a busy college student union. The table had a request for donations to charity and sometimes it had a picture of a happy child on it and other times it had a picture of a suffering child on it. Sometimes the table had no one manning it,
有时桌子上有一个坐轮椅的人。所以悲伤的孩子和坐轮椅的人被Penser认为是同理心触发因素，当人们看到他们时可能会感到悲伤的东西。也许他们也会觉得有义务捐款。他发现的是，当人们看到他们时，他们可能会感到悲伤。也许他们也会觉得有义务捐款。他发现的是，当他把那些同理心触发因素放在桌子上时，人们实际上走得更远了。他们似乎特意避开了那张桌子。这几乎就像他们试图保持身体距离
and sometimes the table had a person there who was in a wheelchair. And so the sad child and the person in the wheelchair were what Pantser thought of as empathic triggers, things that when people saw them they might feel sad. Maybe they'd feel obligated to donate as well. And what he found is that when people saw them, they might feel sad. Maybe they'd feel obligated to donate as well. And what he found is that when he put those empathic triggers on the table, people actually walked further away. They sort of went out of their way to avoid the table more. It was almost as though they were trying to keep physical distance between them
和会让他们感到同理心的东西之间，要么是因为它会感觉不好，要么是因为它会强迫他们做一些事情，比如捐款，而他们可能并不真的想做。我认为我们很多人都有这种经历，例如，当我们看到人行道前方有一个无家可归的人时。我听说过有人过马路
and something that would make them feel empathy, either because it would feel bad or because it would force them to do something like donate that maybe they didn't really want to do. I think a lot of us have this experience when we see, for instance, a homeless individual on the sidewalk ahead of us. I've heard of people who cross the street
以避免那种遭遇，也许是因为他们不想近距离看到那个人的痛苦，因为这会让他们感到悲伤或内疚，或者两者兼而有之。这其中有一个讽刺，不是吗，即那个实际上更有可能产生同理心的人，也是那个可能过马路的人，因为他们认识到他们内心拥有的同理心会让他们感觉不好。
to avoid that encounter, maybe because they don't want to sort of see that person suffering close up because it will make them feel sad or guilty or both. There's some irony there, isn't there, which is that the person who is likely to actually be more empathic is also the person who's likely to cross the street because they recognize that the empathy that they have inside them is going to make them feel bad.
为了避免那种相遇，也许是因为他们不想近距离看到那个人受苦，因为这会让他们感到难过或内疚，或者两者兼有。这其中有一种讽刺意味，不是吗？那就是那个可能实际上更有同理心的人，也往往是那个会过马路避开的人，因为他们意识到自己内心的同理心会让他们感到难受。
Absolutely. Yeah, I've talked with lots of people who identify as empaths and basically say that they're crippled by their overabundance of care for other people and that sometimes they avoid sort of busy cities overall just because they don't want to be inundated with other people's pain. So what happens at the level of individuals, also at some level manifests itself at the level of groups and even the level of nations? White Americans ask to read about the suffering of Native Americans, become more likely to say that Native Americans are unable to feel complex emotions, such as hope and shame.
当然。是的，我曾与许多自认为是共情者的人交谈过，他们基本上说，他们因对他人的过度关怀而感到痛苦，有时他们甚至会避开繁忙的城市，仅仅是因为不想被他人的痛苦所淹没。那么，发生在个体层面的事情，在某种程度上是否也体现在群体甚至国家层面呢？当美国白人被要求阅读关于美洲原住民苦难的内容时，他们更有可能认为美洲原住民无法感受复杂的各种情绪，例如希望和羞耻。
So in other words, empathy not only can produce pain, pain can not only produce disengagement, but we can actually almost dehumanize other people because we're so in some ways reluctant to accept the pain that comes with actually empathizing with them. Yeah, absolutely. Especially if you or a group that you belong to is responsible for that pain. Because then empathy can twist into a sense of guilt or even self-loathing. There are a lot of studies like this, and in one classic set of studies from the 1950s, psychologists asked people to repeatedly shock, electrically, shock, another person.
换句话说，共情不仅会产生痛苦，痛苦不仅会导致疏离，而且我们实际上几乎可以非人化他人，因为我们在某种程度上非常不愿接受与真正共情他们所带来的痛苦。是的，绝对是这样。特别是如果你或你所属的群体对那种痛苦负有责任时。因为那时共情会扭曲成一种内疚感，甚至是自我厌恶。有很多这样的研究，在20世纪50年代的一组经典研究中，心理学家要求人们反复地电击另一个人。
And what they found was that when people had to shock someone else, they ended up saying that they liked that person less, almost as though they were defensively, again, turning down their empathy for that individual. And there's a dramatic example of this that was studied about 10 years ago with death workers in the American South. These are executioners. And what they found is that people who worked on death rows were likely to dehumanize inmates and say that they had given up the right to be treated like people.
他们发现，当人们不得不电击别人时，他们最终会说他们不太喜欢那个人，就好像他们在防御性地再次调低对那个人的共情一样。关于这一点有一个戏剧性的例子，大约10年前对美国南部的死刑执行人员进行了研究。这些人是行刑者。他们发现，在死囚牢房工作的人更有可能将囚犯非人化，并声称他们已经放弃了被当作人对待的权利。
And this was especially true if they were the ones physically involved in delivering lethal injections and the like. So again, in lots of ways, empathy can hurt us. It can be unpleasant or causes to view ourselves in ways that we don't like. And that in turn can cause us to avoid it. When we come back, how to manage this tricky balance? And how we can train ourselves with deliberate practice to be more empathetic.
如果他们是亲手执行注射死刑等操作的人，情况尤其如此。所以，共情在很多方面确实会伤害我们。它可能令人不快，或者导致我们以自己不喜欢的方式看待自己。而这反过来又会导致我们回避它。当我们回来时，将探讨如何处理这种微妙的平衡？以及我们如何通过刻意练习来训练自己变得更有共情能力。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. During his month-long performance art piece, tens of thousands of paintballs were fired at Waffa Bilal in his studio. The white walls of his gallery turned fluorescent yellow. On day 11, a shoot-off from Estonia began bombarding his lamp until it fell apart. It was sad for me because the lamp was just the only thing that stayed alive beside me in this space, especially at night. And it was very sad. Viewers online could see Wafas sadness.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在他为期一个月的行为艺术表演期间，数万颗彩弹射向了他在工作室里的瓦法·比拉尔。他画廊的白墙变成了荧光黄色。第11天，一名来自爱沙尼亚的射手开始轰炸他的灯，直到它散架。这让我很难过，因为那盏灯是这个空间里除了我之外唯一还“活着”的东西，尤其是在晚上。这非常令人难过。在线观众可以看到瓦法的悲伤。
Later that day, one of those viewers came to visit him in person. The lamp was totally broken and I have a person here walked in with a brand new lamp. Hi, my name is Matt, I was watching the camera this morning. I saw the lamp went out. So I had some time, I thought I'd run the target. I got a new lamp and some light bulb. So I know sometimes you need all the help you can get in a situation like this.
那天晚些时候，其中一位观众亲自来看望他。灯完全坏了，我有一个人走进来，带着一盏全新的灯。嗨，我叫马特，我今天早上一直在看摄像头。我看到灯灭了。所以我有点时间，我想我应该跑一趟。我买了一盏新灯和一些灯泡。我知道有时候在这种情况下，你需要一切能得到的帮助。
So, I bring that by and I just help you out a little bit. Jimmy, I'll talk about this moment. Perfect strangers are attacking Waffa, and then a perfect stranger shows up to help him. What do you think causes someone to take the step of saying, this problem is my problem. This suffering is my problem. This suffering is my suffering. Well, it's a beautiful story and there's so many like it. And I think it really, Wafa's story shows you the two sides of how empathy can work in our modern context. On the one hand, you've got people who are anonymous
所以，我把它带过来，只是想帮你一点忙。吉米，我会谈谈这一刻。完全陌生的人在攻击瓦法，然后一个完全陌生的人出现来帮助他。你认为是什么促使一个人迈出这一步，说：这个问题是我的问题。这种痛苦是我的问题。这种痛苦是我的痛苦。嗯，这是一个美丽的故事，像这样的故事有很多。我认为瓦法的故事确实向你展示了共情在我们现代语境下如何运作的两个方面。一方面，你有那些匿名的人
sort of feeling as though they've had the breaklines cut from their social lives and they can do whatever they want without having to worry about the consequences. So they're acting aggressively towards a total stranger. On the other hand, you have someone who taps into that stranger's story, who's paying attention to Waffa, he's watching the video of him and realizing what he's going through, sort of able to tap into the story of this stranger, and that instead of destroying his empathy,
感觉好像他们的社交生活刹车线被切断了，他们可以做任何他们想做的事，而不必担心后果。所以他们对一个完全陌生的人表现出攻击性。另一方面，你有另一个人，他与那个陌生人的故事产生了共鸣，他一直在关注瓦法，他在看他的视频，并意识到他正在经历什么，某种程度上能够与这个陌生人的故事产生共鸣，而这不仅没有摧毁他的共情，
builds it, stretches it towards this person, and drives him, inspires him to help him. I forgot to mention something is really important. Matt is a Marine. Matt wasn't the only visitor. Hi, I'm Laura. I live here in Chicago, so I came down to the gallery, and I made some of my famous muffins.
反而建立了它，将其延伸到这个人身上，并驱使他、激励他去帮助他。我忘了提一件非常重要的事情。马特是一名海军陆战队员。马特不是唯一的访客。嗨，我是劳拉。我住在芝加哥，所以我来到画廊，做了一些我著名的松饼。
That's actually my sister's recipe. I know this the other night when you went to sleep, they had one black sauté and one white sauté. So I brought you some socks. There were lots of people online who had to offer to. Sometimes they took control of the paintball gun by repeatedly pressing down a key and pointing the gun away from wafer. He called them his virtual human shields. Something is really amazing ahead of me right now. I have about 36 or so people pressing the button down on the left, presenting people from panning into my direction.
那其实是我姐姐的食谱。我知道前几天晚上你睡觉的时候，他们有一只黑袜子和一只白袜子。所以我给你带了一些袜子。网上有很多人也提供了帮助。有时他们通过反复按下按键并将枪口从瓦法身上移开来控制彩弹枪。他称他们为他的虚拟人体盾牌。现在我面前发生了一些非常神奇的事情。大约有36个人在左边按住按钮，阻止人们向我的方向扫射。
Here is Wafo on day 31, after stepping outside the gallery building for the first time in a month. And the whole idea is reinforced my belief in humanity and the human kindness. So thank you very much for keeping the hope alive and please keep the conversation going. It may seem surprising that Wafa's month in the paintball gallery left him feeling optimistic about humanity, but he's not alone in that optimism. Jamil Zaki also thinks there are ways we might use technology to form connections with people whom we previously did not see as being like ourselves. He's done work looking at how virtual reality might help people identify with others whose lives are very different from their own. What we wanted to do is use technology to bring people
这是第31天的瓦法，在离开画廊大楼一个月后第一次走到外面。整个想法加强了我对人类和人类善良的信念。所以非常感谢你们让希望保持活力，请继续保持对话。瓦法在彩弹画廊度过的一个月让他对人类感到乐观，这似乎令人惊讶，但他并不是唯一一个有这种乐观情绪的人。贾米尔·扎基也认为，我们可以利用技术与那些我们以前认为与自己不同的人建立联系。他做了一些研究，观察虚拟现实如何帮助人们认同那些生活与自己截然不同的人。我们想做的是利用技术把人们带到
not just to sort of observe the experiences of a homeless individual, but observe them from the inside. So we had a simulation where people went through a series of scenes. These are sort of virtual reality scenes of what it might be like to become homeless. So in one scene, they've been evicted from their apartment and they're trying to figure out what they can sell to make ends meet and stay in their apartment just one more month. In the second scene, they've failed to stay in their apartment and are now sort of sleeping in their car, which is then impounded. And then in a third scene, they're on a local bus line, which in fact, in the Bay Area, there is a bus line that homeless individuals often take to for
不仅仅是观察无家可归者的经历，而是从内部观察他们。所以我们进行了一个模拟，人们经历了一系列场景。这些是关于成为无家可归者可能是什么样子的虚拟现实场景。在第一个场景中，他们被房东赶出了公寓，他们正试图弄清楚可以卖掉什么来维持生计，并在公寓里再住一个月。在第二个场景中，他们没能留在公寓里，现在正睡在车里，车随后被扣押了。然后在第三个场景中，他们在当地的一条公交线路上，事实上，在湾区，确实有一条无家可归者经常乘坐的公交线路，为了
shelter during the night. So again, this showed people in an interactive, immersive way, the process that an individual might go through when they become homeless. What we found was that this short simulation, powerfully affected people's empathy for the homeless, even a month later, people who had gone through that simulation, as opposed to a control condition, were less likely to dehumanize homeless individuals. And they were more supportive of policies that would produce affordable housing for people in the Bay Area, which is a very sort of hot button issue around here. So again, this suggests that by putting ourselves into the story of people
在夜间寻找庇护所。所以，这以一种互动、沉浸式的方式向人们展示了一个人在变得无家可归时可能经历的过程。我们发现，这种简短的模拟有力地影响了人们对无家可归者的共情，即使一个月后，与对照组相比，经历过该模拟的人也不太可能将无家可归者非人化。他们更支持那些能为湾区人民提供经济适用房的政策，这在当地是一个非常热门的话题。所以，这再次表明，通过将我们自己置于那些
who on the surface appear different from us. We can recognize as you put it nicely our common humanity with them and that can trigger empathy in a really natural way. There are also some less high tech ways to get people to walk in the shoes of other people. And one of the things you mentioned in the book is the idea of the theater. How does being an actor in some ways prompt you to develop the muscle of empathy? Yeah, I mean, if you think about what acting is that you really immerse yourself so deeply in the character that you stop being yourself and start being them
表面上看起来与我们不同的人的故事中。我们可以像你所说的那样，认识到我们与他们共同的人性，这可以以一种非常自然的方式触发共情。还有一些不太高科技的方法可以让人们设身处地为他人着想。你在书中提到的其中一件事是戏剧的概念。作为一名演员，在某些方面如何促使你发展共情的肌肉？是的，我的意思是，如果你思考表演是什么，你真的会如此深入地沉浸在角色中，以至于你不再是你自己，而开始成为他们
For a little while I mean I'd say it's more than walking a mile in their shoes. You're almost walking a mile in their skin and and as a result there's some evidence at least that acting in fact bolsters people's empathy So in a great set of studies Taliah Goldstein looked at adolescents who were in performing arts high schools and compared them, you know, at the beginning and end of the year to students who were being trained in visual arts. And what she found is that sort of acting, training and acting, improved kids' empathy more than training in a different type of art, which is not to say that training in the visual arts doesn't have advantages, I'm sure it does, but sort of embodying another person in the way that actors do, almost just like, I
有一段时间，我的意思是，我会说这不仅仅是设身处地为他们着想。你几乎是在他们的皮肤里走了一英里，结果，至少有一些证据表明，表演实际上增强了人们的共情能力。在一系列伟大的研究中，塔利亚·戈尔茨坦观察了在表演艺术高中学习的青少年，并将他们（在学年开始和结束时）与接受视觉艺术培训的学生进行了比较。她发现，表演训练比其他类型的艺术训练更能提高孩子的共情能力，这并不是说视觉艺术培训没有优势，我相信它肯定有，但以演员那样的方式体现另一个人，几乎就像，我
would say a performance enhancing drug for empathy, if you will. In some ways, there's the same goal for narrative fiction, I mean I feel like when I'm reading a great novel, you know, I, as you say go for narrative fiction? I mean, I feel like when I'm reading a great novel, I, as you say it a second ago, become transported. I become a woman who's living in the 19th century. And in some ways, deeply written, beautifully written narrative fiction has this ability to pull us deep into the lives of other people.
会说这是一种共情的兴奋剂，如果你愿意的话。在某些方面，叙事小说也有同样的目标，我的意思是，我觉得当我读一本伟大的小说时，你知道，我，正如你所说，去读叙事小说？我的意思是，我觉得当我读一本伟大的小说时，我，正如你刚才所说，变得被带入了。我变成了一个生活在19世纪的女人。在某些方面，深刻的、写得优美的叙事小说有这种能力，把我们深深地拉进他人的生活中。
Absolutely. Yeah, I mean, this is why I love fiction as well, because it really allows us to effortlessly voyage into the lives of other people and not just see them again from the outside but see them from the inside. There's a fair amount of evidence now that sort of the more fiction that people read,
当然。是的，我的意思是，这也是我喜欢小说的原因，因为它确实让我们能够毫不费力地航行到他人的生活中，不仅再次从外部看到他们，而且从内部看到他们。现在有相当多的证据表明，人们阅读的小说越多，
the more empathic that they become. So there's a number of correlational studies that show, for instance, that children who read lots of story books versus those who read less fiction become more empathic. And that's holds for adults also. Unfortunately for me, reading nonfiction like scientific articles, not that helpful. The journal of personality and social psychology doesn't do it. It's not really the empathy gym that some of us are looking for, but there's also some
他们就变得越有共情能力。因此，有许多相关研究表明，例如，阅读大量故事书的孩子与阅读较少小说的孩子相比，变得更有共情能力。这对成年人也适用。不幸的是，对我来说，阅读非小说类书籍，比如科学文章，并没有什么帮助。《人格与社会心理学杂志》做不到这一点。它并不是我们中一些人正在寻找的共情健身房，但也有一些
experimental evidence now coming out that even small doses of fiction produce small but reliable improvements in people's empathy. And I think this is especially important because fiction is one of the most powerful ways to connect with people who are different from us, who maybe we might not have a chance to meet otherwise. So for instance, you can maybe it would be hard to meet someone who is, I don't know, a Bolivian minor, but you could probably go to a bookstore and find a novel about their experiences.
实验证据现在表明，即使是少量的阅读小说也能在人们的共情能力上产生小而可靠的改善。我认为这尤其重要，因为小说是与我们不同的人建立联系的最有力方式之一，这些人可能我们否则没有机会见到。例如，你可能很难见到一个，我不知道，玻利维亚矿工，但你可能可以去书店找到一本关于他们经历的小说。
And likewise, there's some evidence, for instance, that when people read novelistic, vivid accounts of the experiences of Arab Americans or people of different gender identities than themselves, they form greater empathy for those other groups. We've talked in different ways about how redefining who's in the in-group can reshape our capacity for empathy. You mentioned a very interesting research study in the book involving fans of the Manchester United soccer team. Do you remember that study and if you do can you tell me about it? Yeah I love this study from Mark Levine and his colleague so they recruited rabid Manchester United fans.
同样，有一些证据表明，例如，当人们阅读关于阿拉伯裔美国人或与自己性别认同不同的人的经历的小说式、生动的叙述时，他们会对这些其他群体产生更大的共情。我们以不同的方式讨论了重新定义谁属于内群体如何重塑我们的共情能力。你在书中提到了一个非常有趣的研究，涉及曼联足球队的球迷。你还记得那个研究吗？如果记得，你能告诉我吗？是的，我喜欢马克·莱文和他的同事的这项研究，所以他们招募了狂热的曼联球迷。
And you know, fandom in UK soccer is very important. And they asked them to write about why they loved Manchester United so much. And then told them that they would go to a different building on campus to watch film of Manu playing. While they were on their way across campus, they came across a jogger who appeared to twist his ankle and fall to the ground, writhing in pain.
你知道，英国足球的球迷文化非常重要。他们让他们写下为什么他们如此热爱曼联。然后告诉他们，他们将去校园里的另一栋楼观看曼联比赛的录像。当他们在穿过校园的路上时，他们遇到了一个慢跑者，他似乎扭伤了脚踝并倒在地上，痛苦地扭动着。
This person was, in fact, an actor, and the trick here was that the psychologist made it such that sometimes that actor was wearing a Manchester United jersey. Sometimes they were wearing a jersey of Liverpool, which at the time was Manchester United's most hated rival, and other times they were wearing a blank jersey. And what they found was that man-u-fans were more than willing to help fellow man-u-fans,
这个人实际上是一名演员，这里的诀窍是心理学家让情况变得有时那个演员穿着曼联的球衣。有时他们穿着利物浦的球衣，利物浦当时是曼联最痛恨的对手，还有其他时候他们穿着一件空白的球衣。他们发现，曼联球迷非常愿意帮助曼联球迷，
but also more than willing to basically step over a Liverpool fan as they sort of writhed on the ground in pain. This is sort of classic tribalism in terms of our empathy and generosity, but what I love about this study is that the psychologist ran a second version of it. And here instead of asking man, you fans to write about why they loved the team, they asked them to write about why they loved soccer. Why it is such a beautiful game. And then they put them in the same scenario. What they found was that after writing about how much they loved soccer, individuals were not just willing to help fellow man u fans, but also willing to help liverpool fans. They still didn't help the
但也非常愿意基本上跨过一个利物浦球迷，因为他们痛苦地在地上扭动。这在我们的共情和慷慨方面是一种典型的部落主义，但我喜欢这项研究的是，心理学家运行了它的第二个版本。在这里，他们没有要求曼联球迷写下他们为什么热爱这支球队，而是要求他们写下为什么他们热爱足球。为什么它是一项如此美丽的运动。然后他们把他们放在同样的场景中。他们发现，在写下他们有多热爱足球之后，个人不仅愿意帮助曼联球迷，也愿意帮助利物浦球迷。他们仍然没有帮助
person in the blank jersey, which I guess suggests that it's better to be part of any tribe than part of none, but I think there's a deeper takeaway from this study, which is that yes, it's easier to empathize with people who are like us than unlike us. But all of us have many different selves inside us at any given moment, All of us have many different selves inside us at any given moment, and each self carries with it a different group, maybe of a different size. So if I think of myself, for instance, as a Stanford person, well then people at UC Berkeley are my mortal enemies, especially during the big game. But if I think of myself as a Californian, then my in-group, the people who deserve my empathy and who it's easy to empathize with, that group grows. I think of myself as a Californian, than my in-group, the people who deserve my empathy,
那个穿着空白球衣的人，我想这表明成为任何部落的一部分都比不属于任何部落要好，但我认为这项研究有一个更深刻的启示，那就是是的，与像我们的人共情比与不像我们的人共情更容易。但我们每个人在任何特定时刻内心都有许多不同的自我，我们每个人在任何特定时刻内心都有许多不同的自我，每个自我都携带一个不同的群体，也许是不同规模的群体。所以如果我把自己想成，例如，一个斯坦福人，那么加州大学伯克利分校的人就是我的死敌，特别是在大比赛期间。但如果我把自己想成一个加州人，那么我的内群体，那些值得我共情且容易共情的人，那个群体就会增长。如果我把自己想成一个加州人，那么我的内群体，那些值得我共情的人，
and who it's easy to empathize with. That group grows. And if I can think of myself as, I don't know, an American or a human being, then that group will grow even further. You know, I'm thinking about the story you told me about your parents' divorce when you were a small child. You write in the book about your parents that two people's experiences could differ so drastically, yet
以及容易共情的人。那个群体就会增长。如果我能把自己想成，我不知道，一个美国人或一个人，那么那个群体就会增长得更多。你知道，我在想你告诉我的关于你父母在你小时候离婚的故事。你在书中写到你的父母，两个人的经历可能如此截然不同，但
both be true and deep, is maybe the most important lesson I've ever learned. I think, you know, I often attribute that period of my life to really making me who I am at the deepest level. I mean, I think not for nothing, they say that research is me search, right, at least in psychology, people tend to gravitate towards ideas that have made an impact on their life. And I think for me, empathizing with my parents was a survival skill that I needed just to sort of keep my family together at some level. But it also taught me at a much broader level that people can be fundamentally different from each other for fundamentally similar reasons. My parents had totally different values, not because one of them was wrong or because one of them
两者都是真实而深刻的，这可能是我学到的最重要的教训。我想，你知道，我经常把那段生活归功于真正塑造了最深层次的我。我的意思是，我认为并非没有道理，人们说研究就是“我”的研究，对吧，至少在心理学中，人们倾向于被那些对他们的生活产生影响的想法所吸引。我认为对我来说，与我的父母共情是一种生存技能，我需要它只是为了在某种程度上保持我的家庭在一起。但它也在更广泛的层面上教会了我，人们可能因为根本上相似的原因而彼此根本不同。我的父母有完全不同的价值观，不是因为他们其中一个是错的，或者因为他们其中一个
was a bad person, but because of the lives that they had lived and the experiences that they had had and the things that had hurt them and helped them along the way. I think that this is a lesson that I try to impart to all of my students as well, is that oftentimes when we encounter someone who's different for myself and has an opinion or viewpoint, maybe that we even abhor, it's easy to just view them as being either obtuse or dishonest or both. But that's a mistake.
是一个坏人，而是因为他们所过的生活、他们所拥有的经历以及在这一路上伤害过他们和帮助过他们的事物。我认为这是我试图传授给我所有学生的教训，那就是，当我们遇到一个与我不同并持有某种观点或看法的人时，也许是我们甚至厌恶的观点，我们很容易仅仅把他们看作是愚钝的或不诚实的，或者两者兼而有之。但那是一个错误。
It's something that psychologists call naive realism. The idea that your version of the world is the world. And I think that empathy at a deep level is the understanding that someone else's world is just as real as yours. Jameel Zaki is the author of the War for Kindness, building empathy in a fractured world. He conducts research on empathy at Stanford University. Jameel, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
这是心理学家称之为“朴素现实主义”的东西。认为你的世界版本就是世界本身的想法。我认为在深层层面上的共情是理解他人的世界和你的一样真实。贾米尔·扎基是《善良的战争：在破碎的世界中建立共情》的作者。他在斯坦福大学进行共情研究。贾米尔，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me. This week's show was produced by Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Correll and Thomas Lue. Our unsung hero today is Rosa Portillo. She's a part of NPR's janitorial staff. Every day, Rosa travels the floors of our building, keeping our kitchens and bathrooms clean. She also offers impromptu Spanish lessons to everyone who asks for them. Thank you, Rosa. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter.
谢谢你的邀请。本周的节目由帕斯·沙制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·科雷尔和托马斯·卢。我们今天的无名英雄是罗莎·波蒂略。她是NPR清洁人员的一部分。每天，罗莎都会穿梭在我们大楼的楼层，保持我们的厨房和浴室清洁。她还为每一个向她请教的人提供即兴的西班牙语课程。谢谢你，罗莎。更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。
If you like this episode, please share it with someone you know. When a big obstacle pops up in your life, it can be hard to focus on other priorities. We're hungry, and then this thing starts going off in the head saying, do you realize we're hungry? Have I mentioned we're hungry? We're hungry. Next week, we'll continue our YouTube.O series with an episode about making mindful, short and long-term choices. I'm Shankar Vedanta and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集，请与你认识的人分享。当生活中出现一个大障碍时，很难专注于其他优先事项。我们饿了，然后脑子里就开始响起这个声音说，你意识到我们饿了吗？我提到我们饿了吗？我们饿了。下周，我们将继续我们的YouTube系列节目，探讨做出正念的短期和长期选择。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。